water is one of the most important
resources in farming and today we'll
explore how smart irrigation systems are
transforming The Way We Grow food join
us as we dive into the world of water
saving irrigation technology that boosts
yields and reduces Water waste imagine
Watering your crops with pinpoint
accuracy ensuring every drop counts
while reducing water usage by up to 60%
with smart irrigation systems that's not
just possible it's happening today stay
with us to learn how Precision
Irrigation can help you save water and
increase your Farm's productivity what
are smart irrigation systems so what
exactly are smart irrigation systems
these Advanced systems use real-time
data from weather stations soil moisture
sensors and other monitoring tools to
optimize the amount of water applied to
crops traditional irrigation methods
like flood irrigation or overhead
sprinklers can waste a lot of water
through evaporation and runoff in
contrast smart irrigation systems adjust
water usage based on the specific needs
of the crop and environmental conditions
for example if the soil sensors detect
that the moisture levels are sufficient
the system will reduce or pause
irrigation preventing
overwatering these systems can be
automated and controlled remotely via
smartphone or computer allowing Farmers
to monitor their fields and adjust
irrigation schedules from anywhere this
irrigation technology not only conserves
water but also improves crop Health by
ensuring plant get the right amount of
moisture at the right time the benefits
of water saving irrigation one of the
biggest advantages of smart irrigation
systems is their ability to conserve
water in regions where water is scarce
or expensive saving water is crucial for
both economic and environmental Reasons
by using Precision Irrigation techniques
farmers can reduce water usage by up to
60% depending on the crop and climate
but the benefits don't stop there smart
irrigation also helps boost crop yields
when plants receive consistent and
accurate amounts of water they grow
stronger healthier and produce more this
technology reduces the stress on crops
caused by inconsistent watering which
can lead to issues like overwatering or
drought stress additionally smart
irrigation systems minimize water runoff
and nutrient leeching keeping the soil
fertile and preventing water
contamination it's a win-win you save
water reduce costs and get better crop
outcomes
Precision Irrigation and real-time
monitoring one of the key features of
smart irrigation systems is their
ability to provide realtime monitoring
and control these systems rely on
Precision Irrigation technology which
uses data from sensors to make instant
adjustments to water flow for example if
a weather station detects an incoming
rainstorm the system can automatically
pause irrigation to prevent
overwatering similarly if the soil
moisture sensors indicate that one area
of the the field is drier than another
the system can direct more water to that
specific spot farmers can monitor all of
this data on a single dashboard whether
they're at home in the field or even
miles away this level of control not
only ensures that crops get the exact
amount of water they need but also
allows Farmers to make adjustments
without wasting time or Resources by
optimizing water used down to the
individual plant level farming
irrigation Solutions are driving greater
efficiency and sustainability in ag
ulture case study how smart irrigation
is boosting yields to see just how
effective smart irrigation systems can
be let's take a look at a case study in
California a Vineyard implemented a
smart irrigation system to address water
shortages during the dry season by
installing soil moisture sensors
throughout the vineyard and integrating
them with an automated drip irrigation
system the farm was able to reduce water
use by
45% not only did this cut water cost
significantly but the vineyard also saw
a 20% increase in grape yield the
system's real-time monitoring ensured
that each row of vines received the
exact amount of water needed which
reduced stress on the plants and
improved overall fruit quality this is
just one example of how irrigation
technology can make a tangible
difference in farming operations
especially in regions where water
conservation is critical whether it's a
Vineyard Orchard or row crops farming
irrigation Solutions are helping Farm
achieve better results while using fewer
resources now that you've seen how smart
irrigation systems can save water and
boost yields we want to hear from you
what type of irrigation system are you
currently using and are you considering
switching to a more advanced water
saving irrigation solution let us know
in the comments below and share your
experiences with Precision Irrigation
thanks for watching if you're interested
in learning more about the latest in
farming technology don't miss our next
video on how drones are Revolution ing
crop monitoring be sure to subscribe and
hit the Bell icon so you never miss an
update from Advanced Agri gears